Hi Data 2100 students, as a friendly
reminder with in-class assignments,
I ask you to try and complete
them on your own. So download
the file up above, the assignment
file, try and complete it on your
own, and if you can't get it to
work, then come and watch the
video. I encourage you to always
watch the video after you've completed
it, whether you got stuck or
whether you felt like, hey, I
understood each component of that.
It's helpful to review things that
you may have missed and also just
to double check your work. So
please go and try it first and
then come back and join me in this
video. Again, try and make this
really informal in terms of I want
you to feel like you're in class
with me. So I'll try and ask
questions of which I'll answer
myself, but also show you if an error
occurs, walk through why that error
occurred and how we would fix it.
All right, so let's go ahead and do this.
I'm going to make sure that
I have Beekeeper launched,
so please also make sure
you have Beekeeper launched.
In this in-class assignment, we have six
problems that we're
going to be working on.
And in those six problems, I have
asked you to do the following. So
I want you to submit the text of
the query or screenshot for the ICA.
So you can just be really simple here
about what you submit for the ICA.
For your homework assignments,
though, you're going to submit the
problem number, the text of your SQL
query, and the output of the query.
So just keep that in mind that
for the homework assignment,
I need to have the text of
the query so you'll actually
copy it and then a screenshot
of the output of the query.
So just keep that in mind. I'm
going to show you here on question
one how I would turn this in if
this was a homework assignment.
But for in-class assignments,
I am a little bit
less rigid on those
submission instructions.
Given that we grade it
based off of completion.
So let's go ahead and do this.
I'm going to go ahead and grab
our questions. I'm going to
grab just the first for today.
I'm going to copy those, and
I'm going to come over to our
beekeeper. I'm going to double
-click on this saved connection,
and I'm going to delete
off these most recent query
sheets. I don't want, I don't
need to save any of that.
Alright, so let's go ahead and
I'm going to do a new query sheet.
And paste it in. Okay.
So I've pasted in prompts
number one, two, three,
and four. I like to have
my prompts listed here.
I'm going to, if they run
a little long, I'm just
going to hit enter and
do a couple of dashes.
And I could teach you how to do
multiple line comments a little
bit later on. So let's go ahead
and work on question number one.
We're going to output the first
name, the last name, the age, and the
ski level of all employees, only
include employees whose last names
have the letters double O. All right,
so let's take a look at this. So
I'm going to make sure I have my
Overland ERD and Data Dictionary. So
I have linked the Overland
ERD and Data Dictionary
with this in class
assignment. So here it is.
As a reminder, ERD stands for
Entity Relationship Diagram.
and then our data dictionary,
right, describes every field and
every table. Okay, so let's go ahead
and take a look at this ERD and
my questions. So first one, app
of the first name, last name, and
ski levels of all employees only
include employees whose last names
have the letter double O. So we
know that we're going to be using
the employee table and we're going
to be looking at specifically
that employee first name, last
name specifically, and ski level
and their age. So I'm going to come
over here to my first question.
And I'm going to do, I know it's
coming from the employee table.
Okay.
So once I know it's coming from
the employee table, I hit run. and
I'm just going to show me all the
data in that employee table so as
you're beginning to query is a
good place to start when you become
more and more advanced and you're
dealing with a ton of data we are
not going to do as many select stars
because it could take a long time
to run but as we're learning we're
just going to start out here so
we're gonna say select employee
first name employee last name age
and ski level I know those are the
fields of data I want in my select
statement, that is what I want to
see returned to me. So go ahead
and run that. Okay, so now I'm getting
every single record in my employee
is returning to me, right? All of
my employee tables are returning
to me. Their employee first name,
last name, age, and ski level.
But I want to only include
employees whose last names have the
letters of double O, okay? So if
I know that I want to restrict
the records that are being
returned to me in my output, I
want to limit what's actually
being returned to me, then I
need to use a where clause, okay?
So I'll say where, let's see,
EMP last name, employee last name,
and then we don't want it to be
equal to double O, right? Because
if I do that, if I say equal to
double O, not zeros, it's double
O, then it's like, well, nobody's
last name is equal to double O in
this data set, right? I wanted to
only include employees whose last
names have the letters double O
somewhere in their last name. So
I'm going to say, instead I'm going
to use like, and then I'm going
to put any, I'm going to put a
percentage sign in front of the
double O and a percentage sign after.
Therefore, I'm saying wherever
the double O falls, whether it's
at the very beginning of the last
name at the very end or in the
middle, if there is a double O
in their last name, I want it to
return to me. So I hope, hopefully
you heard what I said there,
that even if their last name started
with double O, it would still
return. Percentage sign means any
number of characters, including
none, or any number of characters
after, including none. Okay.
So let's go ahead and run this.
And now what I see here is that all
of these last name Woods, Moore,
Woods, Cooper, Poole, Woodward
all these are returning to me and
they all have a double o somewhere
in their last name okay so nice
work good work on that so this is
what I would do if I was turning
this in for a homework assignment
I would copy the entire query
okay I would come over here to my
homework assignment I would paste
in that query so command c and
command v or control c and control v
and then I would also take a
screenshot mine's quite zoomed in
so it's a little bit larger for
you to see but I would also take
a screenshot of the first about
10 ish rows of data so I'm going
to go ahead and grab a snip I use
you can use a snipping tool on
windows there's other mechanisms
of taking a screenshot whatever
works best for you but I would
take a screenshot of the output
and again if you can get it to
about 10 rows that's great and
I'm going to place that here
okay so just so you keep that in
mind that I want the the problem
number right number one here
the text of your query and
the output of your query for
homework assignments for in class
assignments I recognize it doesn't
need to be as particular so
you can just copy in the text
of the query or just the output,
whatever works best for you.
I would recommend having
at least the query
here so that you have it for your notes.
Okay, awesome.
Now, same as previous, but only
include employees who are beginner or
intermediate skiers. Do not use ORs.
So if you ever had a question of,
hey, what does the employee
table really look like, make
sure you come over to your
Overland ERD and data dictionary,
and you can say, hey, here's
the ski level filled, and this
ski level field, if I scroll
down to the data dictionary,
this ski level field is the
employee skiing or boarding
proficiency. So if you ever have
a question as to what something
means, make sure you come into
the data dictionary. All right.
So on to the same as previous,
but only include employees who
are beginner or intermediate
skiers and do not use OR. Okay. So
we're not going to use OR. I can
also, if I click on my database
base icon over here, I can click
on this down arrow by employee,
and I can also see all the fields
in that employee table. But
for the sake of the video, I like
to make sure that it's zoomed
in as far as I can so that you
can see it quite well. All right.
So same as previous,
therefore, I'm going to copy
this up above and paste
this down below because I'm
doing the same as previous.
I'm just adding to it.
Only included employees who
are beginner or intermediate
skiers do not use ORs, okay?
So I want to make sure that
they have a double O somewhere
in their last name, right?
And then I also want to specify that
they are beginner or intermediate
skiers, okay? So this must be true,
that their last name has a double
O, and this must also be true, that
their ski level, it says do not use
or. So I can't say and ski level equal
to beginner or ski level equal to
intermediate. I can't do that. So
instead I want to say and ski level
in, right, use that list of values,
in beginner and then intermediate.
Okay.
So again, I'm not using or, so
I'm just going to use this list of
values and say this beginner or
ski level must be equal to beginner
or intermediate and right there
must have a double o in their
last name so let's go ahead and
run this now and this is going to
restrict my output a little bit more so
now i'm only including ski levels here
place here who have double o
right and beginner or intermediate
as their ski level okay so go
ahead and copy this query over,
paste it into that in-class
assignment for me. All right, perfect.
Now, next it says, same
as previous again, but
sort alphabetically by
employee last name. So, same
as previous. So, we're
going to copy this again,
paste it down below problem three,
sort alphabetically
by employee last name.
So, we're going to go
ahead and say, order by
employee last name alphabetically
so I want to be a to z so employee
last name okay I'm gonna go ahead and
run this query and perfect so a to
z as a reminder um order by is
ascending a to z by default so I could
either write it like that or I can
type out ascending okay perfect so
now go ahead and copy this one over
to your in-class assignment as well.
Then down here on question number four
we're going to say same as previous
again, I like these problems that
build on one another, but use a
pointer in the order by instead. So
I'm going to go ahead and grab query
number three, paste it down below,
and I want to use a pointer in that
order by instead. So instead of
saying employee last name, I want to
point to the column, the column number
in the select clause that relates
to employee last name. So employee
first name is in column position one,
employee last name is in number
two, age is in three, ski levels in
four. So as such, I'm going to say order
by employee last name, or I'm going
to say order by two ascending. then
we go ahead and run problem four
and there we get I get the same
answer as problem three just written a
little bit differently so I'm going
to go ahead copy this one and run
it or copy this one and paste it into
your in-class assignment all right
so we're moving quick here through
this in-class assignment again if
you have any questions please let us
know then we're going to do um I'm
going to keep going on this query sheet
again since you're copying it over
into that Word doc. We're not going
to be saving these query sheets.
But let's come down here
on question number five and
six. Those look a little
bit longer than the ones
we've been using before, but
that's okay. We can do it.
So we're going to be here on
five and on six. I'm going to
take a second here and I could
do multiple line comment,
but I'm just going do a couple
of dashes, lines of dashes.
Again, dash and dash.
Reminder,
these dashes, right, this
is just saying ignore this.
Don't, this is not a
query. This is not anything
our code, our processor
needs to worry about.
Rather, it's just a comment.
Okay, so I want to write a query
that it outputs each product its
peak price it's oh it's price
it's peak price and what its super
peak price would be is what would
be if super peak prices were 20
more than normal peak price for
each product oh my word uh that's a
tongue twister order results from
the most expensive to the least
all right so what are we talking
about here we want a product price
peak price super peak price. So
what am I going to be looking at?
What tables am I meaning? What
tables am I going to be looking at?
So let's come up here to our entity
relationship diagram and let's
look at our table. So I know I'm
dealing something with product.
We've dealt a lot with
employee and customer.
The visit product or the visit
table, this just tracks what visitors
came on what day, right so the
date id is the primary key of the
day table comes into the visit
table as a foreign key and it also
the guest id comes into the visit
table as the cust id so and then
it assigns it a random unique
identifier for this customer came on
this day right so that's what my
visit table is doing so it's basically
just think of like when you go
to costco and they scan your
membership they are probably tracking
assigning you a random visitor id
that this customer came on this
day okay um and so that's similar
to to what a lot of different
businesses do then my visit product
is tracking the quantity and price
of what i have purchased that day
and then my winter product this is
these are actually the product's
details of what are being purchased
here in this viz prod table.
So this winter prod, this is where a
lot of my data that I need for this
problem is residing, right? The
price, the peak price, and the quant,
or the peak, really the price and
the peak price. So let's go ahead.
I'm going to do a select star from
winter prod so I can really see what
this is looking like. So I'm going
to say select star from winter prod.
Okay. So my winter Prod.
So write query for each product
that outputs each product, its
price, its super peak price.
So let's run this select star.
Okay, so I'm going to output, when
I say the outputs each product,
I'm going to output the product
name, I'm going to output its
price and then it's peak price
for now okay um all right over
twenty dollars more okay the last
the other thing i can see here so
i i'm working through this so i
select star i know this is coming
from my winter prod table now
i went through and identified
exactly what fields do i need to
select in my select statement then
it says that and what its super
peak price would be if super
peak prices were $20 more than
normal peak price for each product.
Then it also says order
results from the most expensive
to the least. Okay, well
I am going to, I'm going
to say order by, we're
going to use the peak price.
I should be more clear, but order results
from the most expensive to the least.
Use peak price, okay.
So we're going to say order by
peak price, most expensive to the
least. so descending. So the most
expensive will appear on top.
Okay. So we have the adult season
pass. That makes sense is the
peak price senior season pass and
on down. So then we have lodging.
We have adult weekday tickets,
some tuning, some rentals. Okay.
So I'm not quite done though,
because I need to also output
it's super peak price. Uh,
if super peak prices were $20
more than normal peak price. Well,
what in the world? So because
it's listed as something
else I want to output, right?
It's listed as another field.
I know it's going to go in my
select clause. So I'm going to
do a comma after peak price.
And I'm going to say, you
know what? I'm going to
take peak price. And guess
what? I'm just going to
add 20 to it. Let's just
see what happens. Okay.
So I'm going to run
problem number five here.
And again, because it's my
last query on this sheet
and I ended all other
queries with semicolons, I
can just press run. I
don't have to highlight it.
So peak price plus 20. Okay. So
now something output to me. I have
prod name, price, peak price, and
then I have null, but it's doing
what I want, right? It's adding $20
to the normal peak price, right?
It's adding $20 here. Okay.
So that's what I wanted
to do, but it just doesn't
have a field name at this
point. It doesn't have an
alias, is what we call it,
that we can use to reference this
field that we are creating. Now, again,
this field that we're adding here
is only for as long as when we run
this query, okay? This is not adding
it to the database. This is just
a part of the output. We're just
saying, hey, output another field
that is different than peak
price. Just add $20 to it, okay?
So this is only, this peak price plus
20 is only going to exist for the
output of this query. It is not
going to be added to my winter prod
table, okay? It's only just for the
output of this query. All right, so
I'm going to say peak price plus 20
and then I'm going to give it an alias
and I'm going to say as and as um
signifies that I'm going to basically
name this peak price plus 20 as
super peak price and we're going to
do that within square brackets um
the square bracket brackets are best
practice it would run without them.
However, if you had a space between
peak and price, it would then
cause an issue. So I just recommend
putting all aliases within square
brackets. So now I'm going to run again.
And we see here we have prod
name, price, peak price, and super
peak price outputting to me from
my winter product table. Okay,
so super cool. We just created this
column, right, that exists for the
time of this output. And we are
manipulating an existing field
of peak price that exists in
my database, adding $20 to it
and saying, hey, this is the
super peak price. And we gave
it that name. So if we wanted to
share this output with somebody,
we could, and we've created
a super peak price for them.
okay, down here on question number
six, we're going to output the first
name, last name, and age for all
customers with the word son anywhere
in their last name. We're going
to combine the first and last name
into one column and give it the
alias of full name. Also, we're only
going to include guests who have a
season pass or are older than 25.
Okay, so we have a couple of
requirements here, but let's just
start with what we know. And
we're dealing with our guests
here. We call them customers in
this instance, but we're dealing
with our guests. So we're going
to say select star from guest.
And when I do that, we're just
going to press run. And again,
because we have ended all of the
up above queries with semicolons
and say hey these are the end of
the queries then we can just run
this whole sheet and this last
query is the output that we see.
Okay so I want to see the
first name last name and age of
all guests with the word son
anywhere in their last name.
Okay so let's do select first
name, last name, and age.
Okay.
And I'm going to run that. All
right. So now I'm only receiving
this, these three fields of output,
but this time I only want to have
son anywhere in their last name.
So I'm going to add a where clause
here because I want to limit the
records that are being returned to
me. And I want to say where last
name, I don't want to say equal to
son, right it's not equal to it
just that there's sun somewhere in
that last name so i'm going to say
where last name like then i use a
single quotation mark percentage
sign sun percentage sign this says
any number of characters before
sun any number of characters after
sun we just want sun somewhere in
that last name okay and again the
percentage sign the last name could
start with sun this is any number
of characters, including none, okay?
So let's go ahead and run this.
It could also end with sun, right,
as these are ending with sun.
So this sonic-smith, that one has
sun and it's beginning with it.
Simpson, though, is ending
with the last, with S-O-N in
the last part of that name,
right? It's ending with sun.
Okay, so then it also says,
combine the first and last
name into one column and give
it the alias of full name.
Okay, so this is going to help
you on your homework assignment.
And what I want to do here is I'm
going to concatenate. Basically,
I'm going to add together the
first name and the last name.
Okay, first name and the last
name of my guest. And similar
as up above, I'm going to
give it an alias as full name.
Okay, so now when I run this, I
basically add these two together.
It's going to squish them together
into the full name field. So I get
Henry Simpson, Nova Simpson, Tyra
Simpson. I'm going to make this
just a little bit better and actually
give it a space between first
name and last name. And the way that
I do that is after the plus sign,
so I do first name plus, then I
do a single quotation mark, okay?
And I add a space between that
beginning and ending quotation mark.
and then I do a plus sign after
the space okay and before the last
name so what this does is this
effectively gives me a space between
Henry and Simpson Nova and Simpson
so I am adding together these
are fields right that I'm saying
take this data point of Henry add it
to a space so give me a space here
so Henry space and then add it
to the last name data point which
is Simpson okay so I am bringing
together different fields of data
into one column this is really
helpful and we do this a lot in SQL
queries so I wanted to teach you how
to do that and then we're also
going to include their age in just
a separate column okay now again
this is only for the the full name
only exists when I run this output
right it's not being added to
the database it's only existing for
this output. All right, perfect.
Now it says also only include guests who
have a season pass or are older than 25.
Huh? So I'm going to add here season
pass just for a second to my select
clause so I can make sure that I
write this where clause correctly.
So I'm saying also only include
guests who have a season pass or are
older than 25. So all guests must
have son somewhere in their last name.
And they also must either have a
season pass or be older than 25. So I
hope you remember the idea of PEMDAS,
right? Or please excuse my dear
aunt Sally, or whatever other acronym
they've come up with. But PEMDAS
means that parentheses run first. so
basically we want to say that this
they have a season pass or are
older than 25 we want these to be
included in the same um in the same
condition if you will one or the other
has to be the same and they're
going to run first so we're going to
say and season pass equal to yes okay
so have a season pass or are older
than 25 or age greater than 25 okay
so now we see here that son has to
be anywhere in their last name so
this must be true and one of these
two things included in this parenthesis
must be true if you have ands
and ors in a where clause you must
use a parenthesis okay and make sure
that you group whatever needs to be
grouped together like this is one
or the other so we group these two
conditions together and then we say
and this must be true so now when we
run this query here at the end good
job for making it through it we see
here that henry simpson okay has
son somewhere in their last name
they are older than 25 but they do
not have a season pass that's okay
because remember they either have to
have a season pass or be older than
25. So let's scroll down here. Let's
find somebody that does have a
season pass. Okay, let's look at Jack
Anderson here. So Jack Anderson has
last name son in their last name.
Their age is less than 24, but
they have a season pass. So again,
they fulfill this season pass
requirement, but they don't fulfill
the age requirement. Now other ones
are going to fulfill both, right?
Like Colby Henderson has, is older
than 25 and does have a season
pass. That's great. He fulfills
both of those two things and has
a son somewhere in his last name.
Okay. So they can fulfill, they
must fulfill at least one of these
two and for sure this to this last
name like son to be included in
the output all right grab this
query paste it into your in-class
assignment then just make sure that
you turn that in-class assignment
in save it for your notes as
well thanks so much for being here
and for working so hard take care